they've earned their time on the
skateboards by paying attention to the
blackboards it's a deal they've made
with
Ulrika Reinhardt much more open now they
are much more self-confident somehow I
think one of the teachers said slowly
they are coming out of their shells
basically with our rule no school
we are no school no skateboarding we
within no time we reached our goal that
more kids go much more regularly to
school Reinhardt and two volunteers
offer the children's skateboard practice
at the park to build confidence
determination and physical fitness it's
the first part of their deal
I was here when they started building it
I used to work with them I had no idea
about this concept at the beginning I
was clueless the construction work also
confused me an awful lot I thought now
they'll cover it over with a roof but
finally when it was ready and she did
some skateboarding here we realized what
it was a skatepark
she told us our kids would do better if
they were to come here the rule is girls
first here they take priority for once
it's also important for boys to see them
doing well it's the girls confidence
that needs building though you know a
little foyer or drop-in you know a ramp
double her size and they have no fear
the little ones they just do it and they
don't think about it and they have no
fear I have no idea about this I saw it
once on a television I thought one day
I'm gonna do it too I asked my father
how much it was gonna cost I said it
would be very expensive
after the skating school that's the
other part of the deal more children are
showing up now than they did before much
more regular in school now they are more
disciplined and taking their studies
more seriously the older generation in
Jan hua often can't read or write but
their children are learning
the behavior of the children has changed
a lot before they used to play in the
fields all day but they go to school now
and their language has improved this is
stretching horizons particularly for
many girls their futures no longer have
to be limited to field work I'm going to
go into higher education and going to
study the skatepark has been working so
well that local government is talking
about helping Reinhardt start projects
in other villages to
the helping hand offered particularly to
girls from the village may launch them
towards a brighter future the project
was paid for by crowdfunding sourced
from around the world and support from
artists including Chinese master I
Weiwei combining skateboarding in school
is not a new idea but for the children
in Jan hua it's a mix that could help
propel them to a future furnished with
education which will give them more
choice and more opportunities